[Music]
so Jonathan you asked a question that
actually gets to the heart of a lot of
my ideas about science and culture and
you asked about the celebrity culture
you know we hear about these famous
scientists it goes you know Albert
Einstein you know or Stephen Hawking or
Neil deGrasse Tyson we know of these
wonderful kind of larger-than-life
personalities and does that really
reflect what the practice of science is
and in fact it to me this is actually a
deeper question because I think it's one
of the ways that people are kept out of
science we hold up examples about these
these incredible heroic sort of
seemingly perfect people and then we
compare ourselves to them and this is
exactly the same as comparing ourselves
to supermodels and then looking at the
way we look or comparing ourselves to
athletes or to incredibly famous rock
stars so much of our world right now
seems to be set up to make you feel
dissatisfied with who you are and keep
you feeling insecure and in science I
keep being asked by people is it
possible that I am smart enough to be a
scientist do I have what it takes to be
a scientist and there's also the sad
corollary of all of the people who
contact me and say well I see you on
television
you must be brilliant I couldn't
possibly do what you do I wasn't good at
math I don't have the sort of brain that
you have all my life this has made me
feel different and strange and not right
the very moment that I started to get
interested in science I was a very small
kid I was just very curious about space
about geology and rocks I started to be
told Wow
you know you're really different you
know you're not the same as all of us
and you're a girl
wow that's even stranger I mean even
when people were trying to be kind what
they were doing was telling me that in
some way I wasn't right the celebrity
culture of science and the idea that you
need a special personality a special
type of brain to do science are some of
the most harmful ideas about science
that our culture has come up with I
often have to deal with for example the
idea of Albert Einstein Albert Einstein
was incredibly brilliant and he
revolutionized
our understanding of the universe but
there's a myth about him and you may be
familiar with it that Albert Einstein
wasn't really part of the scientific
establishment he was just working in a
patent office he just pulled all of this
out of his brain it was just him working
alone and that wasn't true at all
Albert Einstein was in fact part of
science he wasn't a professor he was
finishing up his doctorate when he was
working in the Patent Office he was part
of the culture and the establishment of
science and he wasn't working alone some
of the major parts of his theory for
example the the special theory of
relativity that deals with how time
slows down when you go close to the
speed of light had largely been
formalized and set up before by people
like Lorentz and even parts of general
relativity his idea about gravitation
and the curvature of space had been done
by people like Lemaitre and others
Einstein was absolutely brilliant at
seeing that different theories that
people were working on could come
together into a wonderful coherent whole
even he admitted he wasn't particularly
great at the mathematics and he had
other people that assisted him with
actually formalizing the mathematics of
how gravity could work so Albert
Einstein himself would have said that he
was brilliant in collaboration that he
actually pulled lots of things together
he wasn't just a lone person pulling
stuff out of his head from first
principles just but by magic the idea
that science is done by brilliant people
who are different than you is just a way
to keep people out of science there is
nothing more difficult about learning
science than there is about learning
anything it takes years to learn all the
physics you need for example to get a
doctorate in physics but I always looked
at it like learning a foreign language
you learn things slowly step by step you
practice you know it's difficult but you
keep going I don't know why we set
science as something different than
learning a language nobody would say to
you you simply do not have the mental
capability to learn French
everybody can there are some people that
are naturally brilliant at languages it
may come faster to them it may be
something that they don't have to work
on as hard as other people but there's
nobody that can't learn
a language and there's nothing magical
about science I have a brain that is
tends toward the creative and the
imaginative I'm not very linear I'm not
very logical I'm not very organized and
I kept being told I didn't have the
right personality to do science and
there's nothing about what science
actually is that demands any type of
personality you can learn something in
many different ways and honestly you can
learn anything if you take the time and
if you practice science can be taught in
a very intimidating way and I suffered
from that I spent most of my college
years so scared and confused
I wouldn't even asked the professor a
question because I felt so much shame
that I basically hadn't understood
anything the whole semester but you take
things over and over again and slowly
they build up the idea that we are led
by single brilliant people is an idea
that I think has at its core privilege
and exclusion and it's time for us to
take back science imagination creativity
you are enough right now to do this you
are smart enough you are brilliant
enough you have everything you need you
can be a scientist if you want to you
don't need me to actually turn something
on inside your mind you don't need to
have been born with something magical
you're a scientist if you can just ask a
question
you